hey everyone this is jeremy shifling at
khan academy i just want to thank you
for taking time out of your super busy
weeks to spend time on today's session
and i want to give a super special
thanks to tim vandenberg who's been
gracious enough to share his amazing
story with us
now as you may know tim has been
teaching for about 25 years including
the last 18 as a sixth grade teacher in
hesperia california and while he's
definitely touched countless lives
throughout his career in the last few
he's really discovered an incredibly
powerful way to help each and every one
of the students succeed through mastery
learning uh 80 of my students are
minority students all of them receive
free breakfast and lunch due to the low
low-income
socio-economic dis
disadvantage of nearly all of my
students
and
10 of my students come to me at grade
level each year from fifth grade to
sixth grade
and which obviously means 90 of them are
below grade level including uh about
half of my class at the lowest level
what california
might call level one uh far below uh
grade level on their previous year's
state test and nearly all of my students
are reading two or more years below
grade level so um if this sounds
familiar to you uh welcome to teaching
because that's what most of us
struggle with here in america we've got
lots of challenges to work with and some
of us are blessed to have a little less
challenges than that but what i want you
to know is that this worked in a in a
classroom with with real obstacles to
overcome these were not affluent um
non-minority students who you know who
have tons of support from home these are
struggling kids so
it worked for them and so i believe it
can work for you and your students too
so next slide jeremy
so this is where my class came from if
you see that little dot on the left side
says vandenberg 1819 my students come to
me
um this is pretty typical
60 points below passing that's pretty
far that's way far and um
the most recent scores i had at the time
for california is 42 points below in
fifth grade a passing score and uh last
year they're actually a little bit
better i got the recent scores
after i made this chart so um and then
the county and district are also low so
here's the point everybody's leaving
fifth grade on average in california not
everybody but on average
pretty low
and you can see california it was two
years ago is my data they went up they
brought their kids one
1.2 points closer to passing
the county brought up their students two
years ago 3.6 points closer to passing
and the district that i teach in brought
their students up
3.6 points more closer to passing so
there's improvement there a flat line
actually means
that you achieved as a teacher a year's
worth of growth because they took a
harder test the next grade level test
and if they stay flat hey you taught
them a year they didn't get any closer
or farther but you succeeded keeping
them up to where they were but positive
slopes slopes that go up that's really
great because then you're bringing kids
closer to their state standards so but
you still see a huge gap there and my
class on the far left way down there uh
far below so we're going to tell the
story what happened so next slide
so in september 2016 i watched this
video from sal khan
where he talked about let's teach for
mastery and not for test scores and
we're not going to show you the whole
video but we are going to show you um
about a minute and a half notice how
sal talks during this video how he talks
about
the insanity of our current educational
system
uh teaching students based on you have
nine months that's it you learn what you
learn and you move on
forget if you have a solid foundation in
your math or reading or whatever you're
teaching
just no matter what you're moving on
social promotion that's just the name of
the game in most schools in america it's
sad but it's just the restrictions we're
given and so
watch as sal explains the insanity of
this education model that we don't wait
until the the foundations of learning
are mastered before building on top of
that so go ahead jeremy start that uh 90
second video
and this will continue for months and
it'll continue for years always at some
point i might be in an algebra class or
trigonometry class and i hit a wall and
it's not because algebra is
fundamentally difficult or because
the student isn't bright
it's because i'm seeing an equation and
they're dealing with exponents and that
30 percent that i didn't know is showing
up and then i i start and then i start
to disengage
and to appreciate how
how absurd that is imagine if we did
other things in our life that way
say home building
so we bring in the contractor say
told we have two weeks to build the
foundation
do what you can
so they they do what they can maybe it
rains maybe some of the supplies don't
show up
and but two weeks later the inspector
comes looks around says okay the
concrete's still wet right over there
that part's not quite up to code
i'll give it an 80
say great that's a c let's build the
first floor
same thing
we have two weeks do what you can
inspector shows up in two weeks it's a
75 percent great that's a d plus second
floor third floor and all of a sudden
while you're building the third floor
that whole structure collapses and if
your reaction to that is the reaction
that you typically have in education
that a lot of folks have in education
you might say maybe we had a bad
contractor or maybe we needed better
inspection or more frequent inspection
but what was really broken was the
process we were artificially
constraining how long we had to do
something pretty much ensuring a
variable outcome
and and we we took the trouble of
inspecting and identifying those gaps
but then we built right on top of it so
the idea of mastery learning is to do
the exact opposite instead of
artificially constraining when and how
long fixing when and how long you work
on something pretty much ensuring that
variable outcome the a b c d f and do it
the other way around
what's variable is when and how long a
student actually has to work on
something and what's fixed is that they
actually master the material
so as sal was saying why do we teach
and have our education system based on
this fixed time model and moving kids
along even though they're not ready for
the next
grade level or
higher level of math skills so um and
that's what he talks about this mastery
learning and mastery learning means
developing each skill to fluency and
long-term retention and i thought boy i
sure wish and i'm sure every teacher in
america wishes that their students came
to them with mastery learning of all of
the the skills that they should have
learned in the previous grade levels and
we all think that what were they
teaching the year before you know well
what were they teaching the year before
that all the way back to kindergarten
and what were they teaching before that
so how about instead we teach to mastery
so next slide jeremy
i decided after i saw that video that
was my huge aha moment i said i am done
dangerously building on the unstable
mathematical foundations it's dangerous
why am i doing this to kids next
so from now on i'm going to teach
students with a solid number sense and
skill mastery foundation i'm going to
make sure my students from now on have a
solid foundation even if i don't cover
all the standards that i'm supposed to
teach i'm gonna make sure that their
life is not ruined when they go to
junior high in high school by actually
having a solid foundation of math and
then maybe i can also teach them some of
their standards for the year i'm
supposed to teach
so
jeremy
khan academy was going to be my tool to
make that happen so next slide
so in fall 2016 i decided my sixth grade
class is going to go back to
kindergarten that's right
we all know
that the holes in a foundation begin
all the way back with number sense
research has shown
that students number sense those
students who have a true
grasp and mastery of number sense
are the ones who succeed well in junior
high and high school math the higher
level of math algebra
calculus and so on they're the ones who
really get it
well what if all of our students had
solid number sense so using khan
academy's menu of class options i assign
to my students
every grade kindergarten first second
third fourth fifth sixth because that's
what i teach the sixth and on the left
column the top two early math and
arithmetic and those two kind of
dovetail with k through
uh
three actually arithmetic goes all the
way to even up to a little bit of
pre-algebra
so i had i signed out to all my students
and i paced out their learning for the
whole year
and
we ended up having some students not
even finish all of third grade but at
least they understood the meanings of
numbers because they mastered k12 for
the rest of their life for the first
time in their life every single student
in my class mastered kindergarten first
and second grade math truly so next
slide
and so for the past three school years
doing this just like this each of my
sixth grade classes have had this the
california state math test i know it's
different for every state but that's the
the big the big high-stakes testing that
our kids in california have to take very
rigorous very thorough
their growth looks like this
you see my little dot on the far side
hey i would be happy if they go up at
the same slope of the county and the
district if they just go up like that
hey we're performing as well as them
that would be great
but let's see what happened jeremy go
ahead
that is real cohort
same kids that came to me that that's
the same kids on the left that you see
on the right that is real growth that's
95 points of growth that's unheard of i
was speaking to a head data person for a
nearby school district and he's in
charge of other state test data
crunching and he told me if he saw state
test scores like that he would assume
the teacher was cheating
but this is real this is kids truly
mastered their standards and because
they had a solid number sense foundation
the grade level standards the sixth
grade standards that they were supposed
to learn
what they did cover what we did teach
they mastered it we we don't just cover
the standards in my class we master the
standards and i would far rather master
half of the year's standards than just
merely cover the entire school year of
required standards but have my kids fail
in their learning so this is real so
let's get into a little bit of how to
make this happen real quick oh by the
way one of the results was khan academy
recognized my homeroom students as one
of seven national grand prize lunch
store winners and that's them those are
real kids and i literally just ran into
one of
the boys in the front row his mom at
walgreens uh yesterday and
and she said oh my son is doing so great
he's now in honors math and junior high
and that's life change i would have
never have guessed that he could have
achieved that based on his fifth grade
state test scores so just amazing all
right next slide
so what is this master learning thing
again i highly recommend all of you go
in and watch these videos it's a two
minute video of sal khan himself
explaining what mastery learning is
highly recommended
and then also what does this look like
in a classroom setting
so
khan
sent their video
crew to my classroom and they filmed for
a couple days and you can see what it
looks like how to make this happen in a
classroom setting if you click on that
second link that's on all both of those
are on youtube so okay jeremy next slide
so here's how i recommend making this
happen first of all be honest and face
the state test facts where are your
students actually at quit pretending
they're higher than they are do they
even understand arithmetic do they
understand the meaning of numbers
if you don't face that reality
and stare the truth in the face you will
never be able to get your students to
truly master the standards like they
need to second
acknowledge that math is cumulative
prerequisite skills are exactly that
pre-required
not pre-suggested
unfortunately we don't have that option
they come to us whether they've mastered
the prerequisites or not but that's the
way math is
and so because
they have to have those prerequisite
skills before i can even teach them how
to add subtract multiply divide
fractions they got to know what a
fraction is they got to know what whole
numbers and fraction parts are and so on
so
we go all the way back to kindergarten
and use khan academy to remediate and
fill in those foundational gaps
and then we teach to the common core
standards to mastery
i do not cover the standards in my
classroom my students do not cover the
standards
we master the standards that is the
expectation
you don't do your homework you master
your homework you don't go to recess
because you finish the assignment and
failed in your learning of it you go to
recess because you mastered the
assignment okay next slide
fifth believe that every child can learn
growth mindset check out the khan
academy
units on growth mindset amazing lessons
use that with your students teach them
to believe they can learn because they
truly can it happened with my students
most teachers would have never guessed
they could and this is three years in a
row that we've seen scores like that so
it's not just a random class has
happened to it's consistent it's working
it's repeatable it's real
sixth
teach support teach support teach
support you teach
you're not just used in khan academy is
babysitting you teach
but then you support those kids struggle
encourage them to come to you for help
watch those videos as sal and his crew
provide online
and use those hints and also have your
students help each other elbow buddies
help them help each other
seventh monitor progress regularly
intervene as soon as possible don't wait
until december to discover your kids are
way behind intervene right away
on eighth
set realistic long and short-term
learning targets you'll see in the very
last slide is a downloadable pdf of my
classes
weekly learning targets how to keep up
pace because i assigned to them to do
every
grade level course every week we don't
just wait till you're done with
kindergarten before you go to first
grade we don't wait till you're done
with uh sixth grade before you go on to
the higher stuff you're working on every
course simultaneously the way the cod
learning pro system works it works best
that way they get more done faster
number eight
i'm sorry number nine motivate encourage
praise reward celebrate when a student
graduates and finishes an entire grade
level to mastery or if you're a high
school teacher junior high teacher if
they finish a lower course to mastery we
literally have a graduation ceremony we
give a certificate of mastery to the
students and khan
has some of those you can download those
i'm sure jeremy can provide them if you
email them later
so that's what we do next slide
so this my class last year
that's 30 lives changed forever i keep
hearing from parents and those parents
there's these students oh mr vandenberg
i'm doing so great in junior high oh mr
vandenberg i was stuck in the low track
for the rest of my life but you
intervened and now i'm in honors math
believe it can be done these kids can do
it your kids can too so
there you go i think that's it last
slide jeremy there's your um great links
check out the cheat sheet on mastery
learning that jeremy provided also you
can email me questions uh suggestions
reach out to me i'm a khan academy
ambassador i'm not paid anything to help
but i want to help and so as an
ambassador i want to support this
program this is changing lives all
across america and the world if it's
used to mastery learn what mastery
learning is and check out that pacing
guide this is just a sample uh you make
it fit your situation but uh download
that pacing guide and um it'll be great
for you and your kids so
okay um jeremy i'll let you kind of take
over i'm going to delete my video here
for a second i'll be right back
first of all i want to give you a huge
shout out tim um you totally rocked our
worlds here even in the middle of
allergy season so thank you so much for
doing that all after a long day of
teaching as well that being said
thanks for all the amazing questions
coming in we're going to go through them
in the order they were received so
definitely stay tuned for lots of great
answers from tim okay so tim i want to
start with this question that was asked
by vanessa ridley who said okay i
totally get where you're coming from
taking your 6th graders back to
kindergarten what is starting with
kindergarten realistic for a high school
teacher
okay that is a great question for high
school i would assign
um literally the early math
um you will discover that your kids will
struggle with the early math skills they
will come along and do great and all of
a sudden hit a standard in that course
and realize wait
i never learned this
and that's the very standard that's
keeping them from understanding um the
the full
foundation and to build all the way up
to the high school level skills i would
assign early math and arithmetic
high school i they don't have time to do
k through
k through
9 lower grade stuff instead
i would assign early math and arithmetic
and that covers quickly all of the
skills that they need to be able to
function in your high school classes or
you may choose instead maybe if you're
teaching a higher level math class
advanced students or at least at grade
level students at least assign the
course before
the the class that you're teaching so
they can get those foundational skills
if you're an algebra teacher assign the
pre-algebra class if you're a
pre-algebra teacher assign sixth grade
but definitely the arithmetic class you
would be amazed how many mistakes your
students will make on their calculus
homework because they're not solid on
their arithmetic
cool great answer tim and sort of a
related question is coming to us from
barb wick she says hey if you're going
to take students all the way back to
kindergarten how do we help them push
through that material when they might
lose interest or motivation saying oh i
don't want to go back and do all that
you count it as part of their grade
and you give a reward
you have contests you know be the great
motivational teacher that you are
um you gotta be the coach the the the
teacher that changes their life and to
and you gotta sell them on this will
change their life for math forever all
the way through college
they have to have these foundational
skills you make your judgment call what
they need
find those skills and assign them in
khan academy but i've got to tell you
having them
as a sixth grade teacher i used to teach
the high math class the year before i
started doing it this way i had my high
sixth grade math class the advanced
students go back to fourth grade
and do the khan academy fourth grade
work they could not do it
the gaps were so huge so i decided the
next year the first year this succeeded
great was have just let's start it back
at kindergarten and you'll discover
kindergarten goes quick they're done in
maybe a couple hours
first grade they might be done in a
couple days so don't think this takes a
year to learn uh higher grade math
students the higher up they are the
quicker they get through it
um and so um
yeah just play with it make it work for
you but i guarantee you the issue that
we math teachers have is their
foundational skills like sal describes
in that video their foundational skills
are still wet
and unstable
and unsafe to build on
and that's the reason why we're pulling
our hair out as teachers
um to get them to learn the current
grade level stuff that we want them to
learn
so you give give them points for it give
them credit i do i count every single
one as in as each course as a grade but
the lower the grade is the less value
it's worth like kindergarten is worth
like
1 6 of a point
whereas sixth grade is worth a full
point
so
cool
lots of questions about the logistics of
pulling this off sarah glotzbach asks
how did you ultimately pace it out was
this during core math instruction tiered
intervention time where did you fit this
in
by sixth grade they have so much
remediation i got permission from my
principal
to allow i'm a self-contained classroom
let's just
be honest we are teaching more than a uh
usual uh 45-minute math block so i had
the flexibility of allowing remediation
during class time
but uh
upper grade teachers who only teach 45
minutes to an hour
you can assign it for homework they
could do it and they get excited they're
like wow i'm i'm doing this stuff
finally for the first time in my life
these lower grade skills that i never
understood
um
so yes i did have time for remediation
but that means other other things had to
suffer but their math and their reading
are the two most important skills in in
all of life
um i love history i'm a history major in
college and i teach ancient history in
sixth grade i love that stuff but we had
to teach less of it um we still covered
it all the standards but um we had to
just decrease our history time a little
bit maybe your high school teachers your
principals can have a math block
just for remediation in addition to
their core subject math class a lot of
classes do that i know the junior high
that my students graduate to have an
extra math block for them to learn from
cool speaking of principles a very
common question is the one that was
asked by maria quintanilla which is did
you get any pushback from your
administration if so how did you handle
that
absolutely so the principal called me in
that very first year i was doing this
2016 2017 the very first year and he
said hey mr vandenberg i'm getting some
complaints from parents that the kids
are on their chromebooks a little too
much
are you teaching and i said of course
i'm definitely teaching but instead of a
textbook
instead of
their answers being written down and for
homework at home or in class and not
knowing if their answer is right or
wrong until the next day when we go over
the homework answers in class
instead they're instantly learning if
their answer is correct or not right
away on khan academy it gives that
little happy sound and the kids love it
that's my textbook but i'm still
teaching
but yes they are on their chromebooks
more please
mr principal i won't say his name to
protect the innocent because he might
listen to this later
please allow
this one year and if the state test
scores are not good i won't ever use it
again but if they're great or
a lot of schools use plc's professional
learning communities where you have to
have
common formative assessments
periodically once every month or so
couple weeks or so if your kids start
rocking
formal assessments and compared to their
peers
then principals start to realize
wow maybe this thing works so when my
students came back that first year the
state test scores blew every other
classroom out of the water in terms of
growth emphasize growth
okay not hey you know we beat the other
class but did we go up a lot that's what
matters is teachers if the scores are
great
if the growth is great principles get
out of the way my literally my principal
just told me earlier this week tim i
will never ask you to change what you're
doing in your classroom because of your
state test scores thanks to khan academy
cool well i know we're at the end here i
know everyone has to either rush off and
pick up kids make dinner eat dinner um
but i do want to thank everyone for
making time out of their busy days to
join today and a special thank you to
you tim for sharing your expertise and
making us all richer as a result and as
a community
that being said i know we didn't even
scratch the surface on all the questions
so maybe
i will work with tim and especially if
you can take some survey feedback right
after this webinar ends to figure out if
a follow-up session or some other
resource will be useful for you and for
your schools
that being said i want to wish you you
and your students tremendous success out
there and i want to thank everyone for
joining you will absolutely get a
recording of the session as well as a
copy of the slides in your email
tomorrow
and hopefully you've been as inspired by
tim's story as i have
and i hope it will carry you far so
thanks everyone and thank you so much
tim
okay best of luck everyone thanks for
joining us
you